next question comes from dr j144 and
this is a good one is larry fitzgerald
current free agent free agent for the
first time in his career under
appreciated i'd argue he's had a better
career than randy moss or terrell owns
maybe he'd get more attention if he had
kurt warner and carson palmer's whole
career instead of ryan lindley max hall
john skelton etc do you think that
that larry fitzgerald given he was in
arizona revolving door of mediocrity for
the most part at quarterback do we not
appreciate him the way that we would or
should if he'd been with a higher
profile team and a better quarterback
for most of his career
i mean
maybe but you could say that about a
hundred players in nfl history
every year when i get in the hall of
fame room we start talking about the
guys from the
uh from the teams the under appreciated
teams why isn't tommy nobis in the hall
of fame he was what dick butkus was it's
just his team lost all the time and i
get that i understand that and there's
no question if larry fitzgerald had
steve young and joe montana as his
quarterback for his career there's a
good chance he'd have more catches than
jerry rice i get that because if jerry
rice had had max hall throwing in the
ball he wouldn't have 1500
whatever 60 catches whatever the number
is
but that's the way life goes
and and i do think sometimes
that we get so consumed
with individual numbers and records and
and all those things that we don't sit
back and realize and think about
the greatness of individual players on
their face okay
without looking at the numbers let's not
look at the numbers let's look at one of
the things that made larry fitzgerald so
great and that is his utter
absolute unselfishness
at a position where divas reign
and you see it time and time and time
again
never in a hundred years
would larry fitzgerald not congratulate
you know one of his fellow receivers
after they caught a touchdown pass or
made a big first down because he's happy
it's a good thing for the team
and and that is one of the things that i
take from larry fitzgerald's career you
heard a lot about at different times
jerry rice's uh you know selfishness
throw me the ball throw me the ball
throw me the ball
and you know you just don't hear that
out of larry fitzgerald because he has
been his entire career a team guy
one of the things i wish we would have
seen more of over the years is larry
fitzgerald in the postseason because he
seems to always find
a higher level when he gets to those
playoff games 2008 an incredible run
that that in and of itself put him on
the the radar screen for the possibility
of canton and he's only built on that
ever since then and peter my theory is
that he won't be back in arizona once
they signed aj green that was that
i think
and i don't know anything here i never
know anything but that's never stopped
me
i think
that fitzgerald and the buccaneers
may be destined
to be a match at the right time you've
got bruce arians there you've got jason
light there you've got tom brady there
you've got a receiver's coach who worked
with fitzgerald in arizona and you've
got an opportunity for larry fitzgerald
to walk off into the sunset with a super
bowl ring for a team that has managed to
hold it all together and i think once
the bucks get to the point where they've
exhausted their effort to hold
everything together and they're almost
there they're down to two guys leonard
for that antonio brown
you can pivot to a larry fitzgerald and
you do it at the right time it'd be the
biggest story in the nfl
on the day that it happens if you pick
the right day to do it
you know mike i at some point i think
you have to look at your team and be a
little bit realistic
that if you're the tampa bay buccaneers
at some point you know you've got to say
we really can't do anymore and and if we
actually did this
it reminds me of all these guys right
now i don't know how the system works in
the nba but all these guys getting
bought out and then they can go play for
whatever team they want the lakers or
the nets or utah whatever it is
and and i just sort of asked myself the
question
you know
i i mean it remind
how how how much is enough
and what do you say to
all of the receivers on your team
right if you were to bring in larry
fitzgerald knowing that bruce arians is
madly in love with larry fitzgerald and
is going to find a way to get him
catches as is byron leftwich he loves
them too
what do you say to the young tyler
johnson you know the the second year
receiver who showed so much promise what
do you say to scottie mitchell who
played a gigantic role in helping you
win the
nfc championship game last year
you know what do you say to antonio
brown you know
and again i'm realizing you're not
you're not worried about antonio brown
but at some point you know you've got to
understand that there's only so many
catches to go around i
i don't see it i'm not saying it's out
of the realm of possibility i i just i
think it'd be kind of foolish
all due respect antonio brown and i
respect the fact that he has managed to
stay out of trouble for the most part
the swap of brown
for larry fitzgerald no-brainer bring me
that
nfl walter payton
antonio brown back right yeah well i
think that may be one of the reasons
they haven't i just have a weird i just
i just
it's it's march 26th and larry
fitzgerald hasn't announced anything
about his future the moment the
cardinals sign a.j green that's when i
say he's not going to go back to arizona
and i just think that that everyone
involved is waiting for the right moment
and it's just going to be
the the cannonball into the deep end of
the pool and people are going to go whoa
wow larry fitzgerald to the tampa bay
buccaneers and i think that just the
last little bit of insurance against
complacency peter because i don't think
they will be complacent not with tom
brady around you throw into the mix a
guy
who wants to go out with a championship
that's just that extra little impetus to
get the buccaneers players motivated to
go climb the mountain that they just
climbed once
you go you want to go back and do it
again because now you're doing it for
larry fitzgerald
can i just say one other thing about
fitzgerald to the bucks look
if they did this jason light
has built this
house of cards you know where you know
he keeps adding one and he's just very
very careful that he adds it so that the
whole thing doesn't collapse my question
is jason light at some point
has to think about
2024
he has to
and he can't just keep borrowing against
the future
with
you know luxuries right now because he
thinks that this would give us
a
one-half of one percent chance more to
win a second super bowl
you know the the the crash and burn of
this team unless the salary cap is 280
million in 2023 or 24
you know could be ugly you know
especially when you have to draft john
doe to be your next quarterback so
i don't know mike i'm not saying it's
impossible i'm saying that financially
i'd have to be really comfortable that
this wasn't going to be
another brick in the wall of uh you know
of a bad construction job for 23 and 24.
eat drink and be merry for tomorrow we
shall be 5 and 12. that's my
position on it go for it now
you know i see you've updated that it's
5 and 12. i like that i'm doing my best
it's taken a while to add in you know
it's been 40 plus years of 6 and 10 5
and 11 seven and nine eight and eight we
gotta get used to adding that
seventeenth number to the analysis even
if it's eight eight and one which uh
probably will happen at some point
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports